This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought to you
by the Toyota Prius.
Let's lead the way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
People talk a lot these
days about our increasingly
fragmented lives.
You know we're living
our lives online.
And somehow, it's not real.
It's not accurate.
We're not really exchanging
intimacies on Facebook
and Twitter is
what people argue.
But there's a term
out there that I
found much more
interesting that actually
says, "look, our
exchanges may not
be the same as in
the meet space,
but they're still
real exchanges."
And I think the term used
was "ambient intimacy."
That seeing bits and pieces
of your friends' and family's
digital lives, seeing
snippets of a photograph,
seeing an announcement of a
birthday, seeing the stuff
that they're posting
does give you
a sort of perspective, a sort
of taste of where they're at.
You are getting an accurate
picture, an accurate snapshot,
an accurate exchange
of where this person is
at in their lives.
There's nothing
inauthentic about
this interpersonal exchange
that's occurring all the time.
In other words, it's
just another space
for communication.
It's not better or worse,
except for the fact
that it does collapse geography.
It gets rid of the limitations
of time, space, and distance,
and allows us to expand
the parameters of what
we can sample.
Right.
The internet is an
infinite tapas bar.
And so maybe we're not having
the full meal of just one
thing anymore, but
we're certainly
expanding our horizons and
expanding our possibility
space, and expanding the mind
spaces where we can travel to.
This indictment of
technology, this indictment
of transformation of social
media I think a lot of times
comes from a place of fear
rather than a place of actually
appreciating transformation,
and evolution,
and how we communicate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]